let's take a look at the conference API
class this class defines the API that
are exposed through endpoints see this
API annotation right here this is what
indicates that this class contains
functions to be exposed through
endpoints there are rules around how you
can name the API and one of the rules is
that the API name must start with a
lowercase letter so far this class
contains a few methods the one that
we're going to be looking at in this
lesson is save profile let's take a look
at it here's the save profile method you
can see up here that we've defined the
at a P method which indicates that this
method is going to be exposed through
endpoints so let's look into the save
profile method you see it defines a
bunch of fields user ID main email
display name t-shirt size for the
display name and the t-shirt size we've
set some default values and when you're
working with your code you can change
these default values as you like you'll
see that the code contains a bunch of to
do's you're going to be filling in these
two do's and the numbers indicate the
order in which to do them so obviously
you do to do one before you did to do to
so the other thing that this method does
is it creates a new profile object
passing in the user ID the display name
main email the t-shirt size and then it
returns a profile so at this point
doesn't really do a whole lot except
create and return a profile object so
let's take a quick look at the profile
class here's a profile class in an
editor and not surprisingly takes
displayname main email t-shirt size
these are the fields that get passed
into it when it's constructed and the
constructor just takes the values that
are passed in and puts them into
appropriate fields the class also
contains guetta methods for these fields
it doesn't contain setter methods
because we only want the values to be
set at construction time so now let's
run the app and see what happens so
we're going to deploy to localhost while
the deployments going on you'll see a
bunch of messages
and at the end you should see this info
dev app server is now running so now
let's go to the browser and see what we
can see so we want to look at the app in
the api's explorer so you go to
localhost colon whatever your port
number is in my case it's 80 80 and then
it's under school aah flash API flash
explorer and then you see the api's
explorer and you see the conference API
so we can drill down into it couple
methods we haven't done anything with
the other method we'll just look at save
profile let's see what happens if we
execute the save profile function just
go ahead and execute it and we didn't
provide any input parameters so we just
got the default response so which is a
profile object containing the display
name without the default that we set and
the t-shirt size doesn't know what your
t-shirt sizes yet cuz you haven't told
it so go ahead and pause the video if
you like and try this out for yourself
now